a failure of leadership behind the
famous black door sue gray's crunch
findings more biting than expected
the report talks of high standards not
being met by those setting the rules of
excessive alcohol consumption in the
workplace and gatherings without clear
authorization or oversight some behavior
she said was difficult to justify
against the backdrop of the pandemic
with nothing overtly critical of johnson
himself it's perhaps not the big
takedown his rivals hoped for a contrite
prime minister appearing in front of
parliament promising to overhaul downing
street and clean up government but no
talk of stepping down i'm sorry for the
things we simply didn't get right and
also sorry for the way that this matter
has been handled
i get it and i will fix it
and i want to say
to the people of this country
i know what the issue
is yes mr speaker yes
yes it's whether this government can be
trusted to deliver
and i say mr speaker yes we can be
trusted
sue gray had been planning to release a
fuller report until london's
metropolitan police stepped in calling
for her to pare down her findings while
they carry out their own criminal
investigation into 12 gatherings
including an alleged party in johnson's
flat
for johnson's opponents it isn't just
about what's in the sugro report but
what's not in it for his fiercest
critics they will have to wait for the
results of the police investigation to
find out more about the most serious
offenses that could cause the most harm
to johnson's political career but the
results of that investigation could be
many many months away
even now he is hiding behind a police
investigation into criminality into his
home and his office the british public
aren't fools they never believed a word
of it
they think the prime minister should do
the decent thing and resign
[Music]
the problem it's not just the opposition
that's been ramping up pressure on
johnson some of his own mps have been
quietly plotting against him
other familiar faces are determined to
hold his actions to account
what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
[Applause]
monday saw a flurry of announcements by
number 10 on the economy brexit and
ukraine this is a government eager to
steer attention away from recent
scandals
but when it comes to partygate there are
still more truths to uncover heads
including the prime ministers may yet
roll if enough members of his own party
decide it's time for him to go
niv barker al jazeera westminster